Eduardo knows all too well that being kidnapped
and then simply disappearing is the biggest
danger facing the migrants.
A few years ago his brother disappeared without
trace as he made his second attempt to reach
the US.
We got as far as Chiapas.
But the police caught me and deported me back
to Honduras.
I went back again to look for him but there
was nothing.
Around 90 members of the caravan currently
making its way north are said to have disappeared
after getting on two trucks.
The reports from various organisations have
not yet been confirmed.
There are differing accounts of the numbers
missing.
Some sources say 80, others 100.
Human rights authorities are looking into
this case.
It's feared they may have been kidnapped - and
handed over to organized crime groups active
in the area where they went missing.
Now, others in the caravan are spooked.
When Jolvin lost sight of his two friends,
he thought he'd never see them again.
"I was really worried that they had disappeared
and I would never hear from them again.
We got separated while I was trying to find
space on one of the vehicles.
I had no idea where they had gone."
Aid agencies say between ten and twenty thousand
migrants have disappeared in the last ten
years.
That's one reason why people are queuing to
get into this tent.
Inside, they can call their families for free,
to reassure them they are still ok.
"We're gambling with our lives.
If you don't fall off the train, you get run
over by a truck.
MAN
"The Zetas cartel runs everything here.
We're most afraid for the children."
Because of the danger, the people in the stadium
divide and register according to the region
they come from.
That way, they hope, any disappearances will
be noticed.
"It's very dangerous travelling between Mexico
City and the US border.
We need to be well organised and able to look
after each other.
We have to know about each other, every individual,
every child."
Organised crime is lying in wait everywhere
on the journey ahead.
The migrants are at risk of kidnapping and
blackmail.
"Criminals lure the migrants with fake offers
of work.
Then they are forcibly held and subjected
to human trafficking."
Attempts to dupe the migrants even take place
within temporary accommodation in Mexico City.
The president of the Mexican federal human
rights commission says migrants are often
approached by people claiming to be officials.
"No-one had heard of this supposed organisation.
They offered to take people in lorries in
groups of 18 north and over the border into
the US."
The biggest concern for the people in the
caravan is to avoid falling victim to criminals
exploiting their desperation.